madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre une vague de panique saisit le
pays les punaises de lit prolifère dans
tous les lieux du quotidien les hôpitaux
écoles foyer de travailleurs maisons de
retraite les prisons les trains ou même
les salles de cinéma elles font vivre un
calvaire aux millions de nos concitoyens
infestés elles leur font perdre le
sommeil provoquent de la paranoïa et les
isolent socialement les punaises de lit
sont un problème national de santé
publique mais vous n'avez rien fait
en 2017 il y avait 200000 lieux infestés
j'ai alerté vous m'avez rionné vous
n'avez rien fait en 2019 il y avait
540000 sites infestés nous avons
manifesté pétitionné désinsectisé des
logements déposé une résolution pour
exiger un plan d'urgence vous m'avez
rionné vous n'avez rien fait en 2020 il
y avait 950000 sites infesté nous avons
interpellé le gouvernement sur l'urgence
à agir vous m'avez rionné vous n'avez
rien fait rien ou presque un numéro vert
et une plateforme fantôme qui a depuis
disparu en 2022 il y avait 1,1 millions
de sites infestés vous avez agi et menti
avec un plan interministériel sans
aucune mesure contraignante et un
observatoire annoncé qui n'a jamais vu
le jour madame la Première ministre 6
ans après c'est votre inaction qui est
largement responsable de cette situation
explosive plus vous attendez plus cette
situation devient incontrôlable quand
allez-vous enfin interdire les produits
chimiques inefficaces quand 90 % des
punaises ont développé des résistances
quand allez-vous enfin cesser de livrer
les citoyens à eux-mêmes et à la
voracité des entreprises privées nous
exigeons un service public de la
désinsectisation gratuit efficace garant
de la santé et de l'environnement madame
la Première ministre ces petits insectes
répandent le désespoir dans notre pays
faut-il attendre que Matignon soit
infesté pour qu'enfin vous
réagissiez
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
ellisabeth Borme première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Mathilde
Panau il y a des sujets qui ne devrai
pas prêter à la polémique et aux
diffusions un peu de déessence madame la
Présidente alors oui les punaises de lit
sont une angoisse pour concitoyens qui
craignent d'y être confrontés c'est un
véritable calvaire pour ceux qui sont
touchés l'infestation d'un logement peut
devenir un enfer pour celles et ceux qui
y habitent et les solutions pour s'en
débarrasser peuvent être coûteuses sur
ce sujet il ne devrait pas y avoir de
clivage il devrait y avoir une
détermination collective pour agir alors
madame la Présidente Panau pourquoi une
fois de plus restez-vous dans l'outrance
pourquoi ne dites-vous pas pourquoi ne
dites-v ou pas qu'il y a un an et demi
en mars 2022 le plan interministériel de
lutte contre les punaises de lit porté
par les ministères de la transition
écologique du logement et de la Santé a
marqué l'attention du gouvernement face
à ce phénomène et apporter des premières
réponses ce plan c'est d'abord de la
sensibilisation pour mieux pour mieux
repérer les infestations et informer
particuliers et professionnels concernés
c'est aussi un accompagnement de la
filière de lutte contre les nuisibles
pour offrir de meilleurs traitements et
disposer de professionnels formés et
reconnus c'est en effet une meilleure
observation du phénomène avec un
observatoire qui est en cours de
création mesdames et messieurs les
députés les punaises de lit ont infesté
la plupart des grandes villes du monde
les études nous montrent que leur
prolifération est liée au voyage
touristique et à la résistance aux
insecticides pour autant nous sommes
déterminés à continuer à agir et ier
notre action et une réunion avec
l'ensemble des ministères concernés se
tiendra dans les prochains jours et la
majorité présidentielle a engager un
travail pour trouver des réponses de
long terme sur la détection
l'infestation et l'accompagnement des
personnes touchées une réflexion qui
devrait pouvoir rassembler largement
dans cet hémicycle alors travaillons
ensemble trouvons des solutions ensemble
je vous
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre